[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen Abend wünsche ich
Ihnen den Sport hat Christian Otto für
sie voller Freude guten Abend und wir
schauen auf die Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts zum
heizungsgesetz
Zwangspause für das umstrittene
heizungsgesetz nach dem Stopp durch das
Verfassungsgericht will die
Ampelkoalition erst nach der Sommerpause
im Bundestag darüber abstimmen
Depressionen Angst oder Essstörungen
viele Jugendliche leiden noch immer an
den Folgen von Schulschließungen und
kontaktverboten während der
corona-pandemie
und Kraftakt in den Pyrenäen bei der
Tour de France erkämpft sich den Etappen
Sieg und liegt nur noch knapp hinter mit
Favorit Jonas weniger Gott
die ampelkonditionen wollte das
heizungsgesetz besonders schnell durch
den Bundestag bekommen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat das jetzt
gestoppt im Grunde hat es Zweifel daran
angemeldet dass sie Abgeordneten
ausreichend Zeit hatten den
Gesetzentwurf durchzugehen die Koalition
wird das Gesetz nun erst Anfang
September im Bundestag verabschieden
über die Reaktion auf die Karlsruhe
Entscheidung Berichte Klaus Brodbeck
er hat das heizungsgesetz gestoppt kein
Triumph sagt Thomas Heilmann
Abgeordneter der CDU es gehe ihm gar
nicht um dessen Inhalt sondern darum
künftig wieder Gesetze gründlich beraten
zu können wenn man ehrlich ist leiden
die Verfahren des Deutschen Bundestages
seit längerem auch schon in der letzten
Legislaturperiode
an
mangelnder Sorgfalt der Beschluss
überraschte die Ampel kalt die
Verabschiedung vor der Sommerpause
sollte den Streit der vergangenen Wochen
vergessen machen und es ist kein
Ruhmesblatt aber wir wollten den
Menschen auch durch eine abschließende
Lesung im gesamten deutschen Bundestag
Sicherheit geben aber in dem der
Fachausschuss jetzt auch durch die
Formulierungshilfen durch
Änderungsanträge Klarheit hineingebracht
wird kann man sich daran bereits
orientieren die Koalition möchte das
Gesetz nun nach dem Sommer ohne
Änderungen beschließen
Karlsruhe hat nicht über das Gesetz
geurteilt sondern hat den Bundestag als
Organ angemahnt hier ruhiger zu beraten
und ich finde es deshalb richtig dass
wir genau dieser ruhigeren Beratung
jetzt Nachkommen damit haben dann auch
tatsächlich alle Mitglieder des
Deutschen Bundestages noch einmal
ausreichend Zeit sich mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf zu beschäftigen die Union
aber will erneut auch über Inhalte
verhandeln wir bieten der Koalition
ausdrücklich an dass wir noch mal
gemeinsam darüber beraten wie wir das
bestehende Gebäude Energiegesetz keine
Erfindung dieser Koalition sondern es
gibt ein Gebäude Energiegesetz wie wir
das bestehende Gebäude Energiegesetz
noch einmal verbessern können auch DIE
LINKE fordert weitere Beratungen und
Belange aller Beteiligten ausführlicher
debattieren zu können
Kommunen und die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
können sich dann besser einstellen und
die große Lehrstelle des sozialen
Ausgleiches könnte von der
Bundesregierung dann mit Substanz
gefüllt werden der Streit und Verfahren
beendet der Streit um Inhalte geht wohl
weiter am ersten Januar soll das Gesetz
in Kraft treten
und das ganze beobachtet für uns auch
Karl Hinterleitner Karl was sagt das
jetzt aus über die Regierungsarbeit ja
sicher nichts Positives zwar bedeutet
die Entscheidung aus Karlsruhe nur eine
Verschiebung aber natürlich kommen jetzt
Stimmen aus der Opposition die das ganze
Gesetz wieder in Frage stellt und auch
die eigenen Reihen sind ja alles andere
als geschlossen so meinte etwa Wolfgang
Kubicki immerhin Vize-Vorsitzender der
FDP dass alles sei eine verdiente
Quittung für die Grünen das hört sich
gerade so an als sei die FDP überhaupt
nicht dabei gewesen partnerschaftliches
regieren geht wohl anders und der
nächste Konflikt in der Ampel der wurde
heute so eben noch vermieden SPD und vor
allem grüne wollten das Gesetz jetzt
endlich vom Tisch haben und das wäre mit
einer Sondersitzung des Bundestages in
den kommenden 12 Wochen noch durchaus
möglich gewesen aber auch das wollte die
FDP nicht jetzt wartet mal ein bisschen
September also bis nach der Sommerpause
und der Streit um das Gesetz kann da
noch Monate lang weitergehen so oder so
politisch ist das ganze eine saftige
Ohrfeige für die Koalition das
umstrittene Heizungs Gesetz und jetzt
auch noch zur politischen dauerbrenne zu
werden danke für die Einschätzung
im Bundestag wurde heute über ein Thema
abgestimmt dass viel nahe geht die
Sterbehilfe zwei Gesetzentwürfe lagen
auf dem Tisch die die Hilfe zur
Selbsttötung Regeln wollten denn 2020
hatte das Bundesverfassungsgericht das
Verbot der geschäftsmäßigen Sterbehilfe
gekippt und eine Neuregelung angemahnt
aber keiner der beiden Gesetzentwürfe
bekam heute die notwendige Mehrheit
Britta Buchholz
es geht nicht nur um alte nicht um
Kranke es geht um jeden von uns es geht
um die Entscheidung wie soll unser Leben
enden eine Parlamentariergruppe waren
vor einem assistierten Suizid als
Normalität das müsse verhindert werden
ich mache mir Sorgen um die die denken
sie fallen nur noch anderen zu lassen
um die die sich fragen ist mein Leben
noch etwas wert
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen solche
Fragen müssen Menschen mit sich selbst
ausmachen
aber wir als Gesellschaft sollten ihn zu
rufen ja dein Leben ist etwas Wert jedes
Leben in diesem Land ist wertvoll
sein Vorschlag gilt als der striktere
nach diesem Entwurf soll die Hilfe zur
Selbsttötung bestraft werden bis auf
weniger Ausnahmen zum Beispiel bräuchte
ein suizidwilliger zwei Gespräche mit
einem Facharzt für Psychiatrie der
zweite liberalere Entwurf will ein Recht
auf selbstbestimmte sterben ohne
Strafgesetzbuch dafür sollte ein
Beratungsangebot ähnlich der
Schwangerschaftskonfliktberatung
entwickelt werden
nur über tatsächlichen Zugang können wir
im Übrigen auch Menschen helfen die aus
der Bahn geraten sind wenn es das
Grundrecht ist selber über das Ende des
Lebens zu entscheiden und sich dabei
einer Hilfe zu bedienen können wir nicht
in Strafgesetzbuch eine Regelung
aufnehmen die sagt die Hilfe zu einem
selbstbestimmten frei Verantwortlichen
Suizid ist grundsätzlich strafbar die
Zerrissenheit der Parlamentarier zeigte
sich von Anfang an beide Vorschläge
fallen schließlich durch und damit
bleibt die Sterbehilfe in einer Grauzone
für sterbenskranke eine Zumutung Helmut
Feldmann klagte vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht und wartet nun
seit drei Jahren auf eine Regelung er
leidet an einer schweren Lungenkrankheit
und will sein Ende selbst bestimmen
es ist eine Schande für den Deutschen
Bundestag und eine Schande für
Deutschland
dass das
damengesetz der Sterbehilfe immer noch
nicht in trockenen Tüchern ist
die Gesetzentwürfe abgelehnt die
Sterbehilfe bleibt ungeregelt es wurde
keine Sternstunde des Parlaments
wenn ihr heter woran hat es denn gelegen
dass es für keinen der Gesetzentwürfe
eine Mehrheit gab
es gab nicht den einen Grund es gab bei
einem Teil der Abgeordneten Ängste und
Vorbehalte dass hier die Hilfe zum
Suizid normalisiert werden könnte dass
Menschen sich gedrängt fühlen könnten
zum Tod um andere nicht zu Last zu
fallen und das wollten einige nicht
unterschreiben und dazu kommt dass es
eine inhaltliche Verunsicherung gab
durch die Expertenanhörung im Vorfeld da
hatten insbesondere Ärzteverbände darauf
hingewiesen dass es diese ganzen
beratungsstrukturen die in beiden
Entwürfen gefordert werden in
Deutschland so noch gar nicht vorhanden
sind so und zu dieser inhaltlichen
Verunsicherung kommt dann der Zeitpunkt
der Debatte wir sind hier in Berlin das
erleben wir seit Tagen zwischen
Haushaltsberatung und ampelstreit zum
heizungsgesetz und ich würde behaupten
dass da einigen Parlamentarierinnen und
Parlamentariern schlichtweg die Zeit und
die Muße und die Kraft gefehlt hat sich
so richtig in dieses Thema zu verbohren
und da hat ihr Gewissen ihn auf dem Weg
zur Wahl ohne eben nein gesagt und fällt
noch ein letzter aber nicht ganz
unwichtiger Punkt politische Themen
brauchen immer Gesichter die sich damit
verbinden und in dieser Debatte hat es
einfach gefehlt dass jemand dieses Thema
Sterben tot Suizid in die Öffentlichkeit
bringt und damit eben auch
Öffentlichkeit schafft und dadurch kam
heute eben diese Ablehnung bei der
Gesetzentwürfe Zustande danke
die Bundesanwaltschaft hatte
Nordrhein-Westfalen eine mutmaßliche
islamistische Terrorzelle ausgehoben
sieben Verdächtige wurden festgenommen
Innenministerin Phaser spricht von einem
bedeutenden Schlag die Männer aus
Tadschikistan kirgistano Turkmenistan
wurden in Karlsruhe die
Ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt sie sollen
Anschläge geplant und Geld für den is
gesammelt haben kurz nach dem russischen
Überfall waren die Verdächtigen aus der
Ukraine nach Deutschland eingereist
wieder schwere Angriffe von Russland
gegen die Ukraine und wieder traf es
auch die Zivilbevölkerung weit hinter
der Front mindestens fünf Menschen kamen
in Lemberg ums Leben mehrere
Marschflugkörper waren vom Schwarzen
Meer aus abgefeuert worden Lemberg liegt
ganz im Westen der Ukraine über 500 km
von der Frontlinie entfernt bluten
leinhaus berichtet
völlige Zerstörung russische Raketen
haben den alt ehrwürdigen Wohnblock in
Lembergs Innenstadt in Schutt und Asche
gelegt die Wohnungen in den oberen
Stockwerken existieren nicht mehr eine
solche Attacke hat es seit Kriegsbeginn
nicht gegeben sagt der Bürgermeister
dies ist der schwerste Angriff auf ein
ziviles Ziel in Lemberg überhaupt es
gibt viele Tote und Verwundete
noch immer sind Suchtrupps im Einsatz
und hoffen unter den Trümmern
Überlebende zu finden Bilanz der Retter
bislang fünf Tote und mehr als 30
Verletzte
wer die Raketen überlebte hat außerdem
leben so gut wie alles verloren die
Reaktionen zwischen Erleichterung und
Wut
als ich eben aus dem Krankenhaus
zurückkam habe ich erfahren dass meine
Mutter und meine Nachbarn tot sind es
scheint das sah ich die einzige die aus
dem vierten Stock überlebt hat es ist
ein Wunder
die Rosen behaupten dass sie
militärische Ziele bombardieren aber sie
treffen ein friedliches Haus in dem die
Menschen schlafen wie können Sie so
etwas tun
die russischen Raketen kamen vom
Schwarzen Meer sagt die Ukraine zuerst
sein sie Richtung Kiew geflogen und dann
plötzlich nach Lemberg abgedreht
Präsident selensky spricht von einem
nächtlichen Angriff russischer
Terroristen und kündigt eine handfeste
Reaktion an
die Bewohner von mehr als 60 Wohnungen
haben vergangene Nacht ihr zu Hause
verloren in Lemberg mehr als 500 km von
der Frontlinie entfernt
in Israel gab es in der Nacht wieder
Proteste gegen die umstrittene
Justizreform dieses mal recht spontan
nachdem der Polizei-Chef von Tel Aviv
seinen Rücktritt erklärt hatte in der
Stadt blockierten tausende Menschen eine
Autobahn die Regierung hatte den
polizeischiff aufgefordert gewaltsam
gegen die Proteste vorzugehen er hatte
sich geweigert und war als er versetzt
werden sollte zurückgetreten
Kinder aus finanzschwachen Familien
besser fördern wie viel Geld das kosten
darf darüber streitet sich die Koalition
seit Monaten eine Umfrage zum
kinderreport 2023 des deutschen
Kinderhilfswerks ergab jetzt die große
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung hält die
bisherigen Maßnahmen für unzureichend
demnach finden 72% der Erwachsenen sowie
61% der Kinder und Jugendlichen dass es
eher wenig oder sogar sehr wenig gegen
Kinderarmut getan wird bei der Frage wie
die Armut bekämpft werden sollte sagen
die allermeisten Befragten kostenlose
Bücher und Lehrmittel mehr Fachkräfte an
Schulen und Kitas mehr günstiger
Wohnraum
und noch ein Thema das Kinder und
Jugendliche belastet die Auswirkungen
der corona-maßnahmen
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
waren heute deshalb auch vor hohen
wirtschaftlichen Kosten denn die
Pandemie wirkt nach Anfang dieses Jahres
waren laut Familienministerium 73
Prozent der jungen Menschen noch enorm
gestresst durch die Einschränkungen von
damals
Einsamkeit ist ein großes Problem nicht
wenige sind psychisch erkrankt
Angststörungen Depressionen Essstörungen
sich genug Essen zu nehmen ist für sie
jedes Mal eine Herausforderung charlotte
hat in der Lehre des lockdowns eine
Essstörung entwickelt schon zum zweiten
Mal ist sie in Behandlung in einer
Spezialklinik am Chiemsee nicht Corona
selbst sondern die Isolation war das
Problem ich glaube einfach dass ich
einfach überhaupt keine Möglichkeit
hatte mich da irgendwie dann abzulenken
und irgendwie doch sozusagen das sind
vom Leben zu sehen warum sich lohnt
jetzt da nicht irgendwie weiter dran zu
arbeiten sich runter zu hungern weil ich
mal einfach nicht die Möglichkeit hatte
sich mit Freunden zu treffen das zu
machen was einem Spaß macht was sie
bewegt bespricht Charlotte mit ihrer
Therapeutin während der Pandemie hatten
sich psychische Probleme wie etwa
Angststörungen bei jungen Menschen
verdoppelt die Familienministerin stellt
heute eine neue Studie vor sie
untersucht die wirtschaftlichen Folgen
von psychischen Belastungen bei jungen
Menschen durch die Pandemie die haben
halt erhebliche Folgekosten für die
Zukunft sie betragen eben je nach
Szenario zwischen 2,8 und 5,6 Milliarden
Euro
der Kosten entstehen durch Therapien und
Behandlungen aber auch später im Leben
durch Ausfälle bei Ausbildung und Arbeit
aufgrund einer psychischen Erkrankung
bin gespannt wenn die einmal begonnen
hat dann dauert das auch über die
Pandemie an und hat wir erleben auch
jetzt noch nach der Pandemie ein
vermehrten
Behandlungsbedarf nach wochenlanger
Therapie spürt Charlotte Fortschritte
ich bin auf jeden Fall ein großes Stück
weiter aber man merkt selber manchmal
die Situation wo man einfach merkt dass
man noch nicht der alte Mensch ist dass
man immer noch die Krankheit hat die
Essstörung aus dem Kopf zu bekommen für
Charlotte und die vielen anderen
Betroffenen ist es ein langer Weg
wenige deutsche Künstler dagegen war
sind international so bekannt und
geschätzt wie am selben Kiefer jetzt ist
78-Jährige in Berlin mit dem deutschen
Nationalpreis geehrt worden meine
Biografie ist die Biografie Deutschlands
hat Kiefer einmal gesagt sein Werk
spiegelt vor allem die düsterin Kapitel
der deutschen Geschichte auf dem Braun
oder Grau monumental zwischen Malerei
und Skulptur und fast immer mit
abstrakter Wucht
noch einmal Satelliten ins All bringen
das war die letzte Aufgabe von Ariane 5
gestern Nacht 27 Jahre lang war die
europäische schwerlastrakete im Einsatz
jetzt ist Schluss an Arian ist
Nachfolgerin wird schon lange gebaut
aber noch ist sie nicht am Start von
einem Abschied mit einem kleinen
bisschen Wehmut berichtet David
der letzte Stab der Ariane 5 zweimal
verschoben zunächst wegen technischer
Probleme dann wegen des Wetters nun ein
Erfolg und ein emotionaler Moment
gefeiert auch in Bremen wo die
Oberstufen der Raketen gebaut werden
macht mich glücklich weil ich weiß dass
das die Teams die dahinter stehen so
intensiv dran gearbeitet haben dass auch
die letzte Ariane 5 genau das macht was
eigentlich jede Ariane 5 gemacht hat die
Erfolgsgeschichte der unbemannten
Trägerrakete begann mit einer Panne der
erste Start vor 27 Jahren schlug fehlt
doch anschließend bringt die Ariane 5 so
zuverlässig ihre Fracht in den Orbit das
unter anderem die NASA ihr das
Weltraumteleskop James Web anvertraut
die Ariane 5 galt als Europas Zugang ins
All der fällt nun erst einmal weg denn
der Staat der Nachfolger Rakete
verzögert sich durch die corona-pandemie
und technische Probleme seit Jahren
wir haben einen vorübergehendes Problem
durch den noch nicht erfolgten
Jungfernflug der Ariane 6 und nach dem
Fehlstart der Vega C Rakete aber wir
werden weiterhin unabhängigen Zugang zum
allhaben
Gehen von sechs oder sieben Monaten ganz
ohne europäische Trägerraketen aus
meiner Zeiten der die Konkurrenz mit
günstigeren wiederverwendbaren Raketen
den marktrevolutioniert könnte die
Ariane 6 ist schwerer haben an den
Erfolg der Ariane 5 anzuknüpfen
Erleichterung beim Tennis in Wimbledon
kein Regen das konnte gespielt werden
Dienstag auf sein erster runden Match
warten müssen am frühen Nachmittag ging
es an endlich los etwas mühsam aber
letztlich doch erfolgreich gegen einen
widerspenstigen Qualifikanten aus den
Niederlanden
Alexander es wäre hat sich durchgekämpft
der 13.07 klingt einfacher als er war
das Match insgesamt auf Augenhöhe Sat.1
gewinnt der deutsche gegen den
Niederländer heiß Brauer zwar mit viel
zu 6 doch seit zwei und drei gehen in
den Tie Break es immer wieder mit
Problemen aber letztlich holt er sich
drei Matchbälle vergab zwar zwei aber
nutzte den letzten beendete das Spiel
mit einem Ass damit trifft der
26-Jährige in der zweiten Runde auf
Yosuke aus Japan
und bereits in Runde 3 steht erstmalig
Maximilian Matera durch einen
dreisatzerfolg gegen den Amerikaner
Michael Moore bei den Frauen gewann
überraschend Jule Niemeyer ihre
Auftaktpartie gegen Carolina muchova mit
sechs vier fünf sieben und sechs eins
die Tschechien hat er sich allerdings im
dritten Satz am Oberschenkel verletzt
und zur Tour de France da hat sich auf
der 6 Etappe der zweimalige
gesamtsiegert HD aus Slowenien
eindrucksvoll zurückgemeldet und in den
Pyrenäen die erste Berg Ankunft gewonnen
frankreichs Staatspräsident macron
hautnah dabei als die Entscheidung fällt
2,8 km vor dem Ziel in Côte im weißen
Trikot seinem großen Kontrahenten
vorjahresieger Jonas weniger und kann
ihm 28 Sekunden abnehmen gestern noch
warten die schwächer als der denen wegen
Georg heute auf der schwierigen Etappe
mit dem 2100 m hohen Trummer Lee glänzt
der Slowene der Sieger der Tour 2020 und
21 das Gelbe Trikot erobert der Tages 2
ginge im Ziel in prominenter
Gesellschaft liegt jetzt 25 Sekunden vor
puderschaft
ein Höhepunkt zu Beginn der Finals in
Rhein-Ruhr der insgesamt 24 Meistertitel
für die Kunstturnerin Elisabeth die sich
in Düsseldorf im meerkampf der Frauen
durchsetzte
zwei Jahre nach ihrem letzten Mehrkampf
bei den Olympischen Spielen in Tokio
steht Elisabeth Seitz wieder ganz oben
wird zum 9 mal deutschmeisterin im
meerkampf zu stehen beim Deutschen
Meisterschaften und tatsächlich Deutsche
Meisterin zu werden das bedeuten wir
wahnsinnig viel die Entscheidung für
seit vielen bei der finalen Disziplin am
Boden ein Herzchen für die Fans zuvor
hatte sie schon am Stufenbarren gewonnen
bis zum letzten Gerät übte immer
Malewski Druck auf Salz aus die
18-Jährige Schwebebalken Europameisterin
gewann letztlich aber Silber vor Pauline
Schäfer Betz die dritte wurde
ausgelassene Freude aber bei einer
großen Turnerin die 29-Jährige deutsche
rekordmeisterin elisabeth
der Landung musste noch sein und die
finale morgen auch wieder im Livestream
unter sportstudio.de danke schön
Christian
kommt eine Hitzewelle auf uns zu mehr
dazu gleich von essen um 21:45 Uhr läuft
das heute journal mit Christian Sievers
und morgen übernimmt hier an dieser
Stelle Barbara haibik bis bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Hitzewelle
kündigt sich nun allmählich an wir haben
morgen schon in Mitteleuropa
Temperaturen um 30 Grad Richtung
Mittelmeer 35 Grad und die Hitze die
kommt von Nordafrika hoch sehen ist hier
in dieser Luftmasse sind Höchstwerte von
30 bis 40°c möglich und so steigen die
Temperaturen am Sonntag auf 37 Grad der
Reihe nach in der Nacht gibt es einen
stern-clan Himmel höchstens ganz im
Norden bildet sich Nebel und Sie haben
die Gelegenheit noch mal ordentlich
durchzulüften die Wohnung abzukühlen
Temperaturen gehen bis auf 9 Grad runter
den nächsten Tagen wird es eben heiß
morgen dann einige harmlose Wolken nach
Nordosten hin oder in Bayern aber oft
ist es sonnig bei höchsten Temperaturen
von 23 Grad in Schleswig-Holstein und
schon mal heißen 32 Grad im
Rhein-Main-Gebiet oder zum Beispiel am
Oberrhein und die nächsten Tage geht's
weiter mit der Hitze 35 gerade am
Samstag erste Hitze Gewitter am Sonntag
37 Grad die Gewitter nehmen schon mal zu
können schon stark kriegen mitbringen ja
und Montag ebenfalls teils heftige
Gewitter damit einen schönen Abend